[Applaudissements]
c'est toi qui pue
[Musique]
quand même vous voulez pas ouvrir la
fenêtre
[Musique]
quand on dit Rousseau ou tout simplement
Paul de carotte on désigne en général
une personne qui a des cheveux plus ou
moins oranges mais en écrivant cet
épisode j'ai remarqué que la vie c'est
pas vraiment comme dans les dessins
animés il existe une très grande variété
de nuances de roues du blond avec des
reflets oranges clairs jusqu'au rousse
sombre moi par exemple selon les
coiffeurs la nuance de couleur de mes
cheveux c'est camel à l'échelle mondiale
on retrouve des roues partout et il
représente environ 2% de la population
avec une plus forte concentration au
Royaume-Uni en France et plus
généralement en Europe mais aussi dans
certaines populations au Maghreb au
Proche-Orient et dans les îles Salomon
pour affiner cette définition de roue je
me suis donc intéressé à l'origine de la
couleur de cheveux et plus précisément
au mélanocyte des cellules un peu
spéciales présentes dans notre peau
notre cuir chevelu nos iris et même dans
notre tube digestif ce sont des cellules
assez mignonnes avec des petits bras par
lesquels sont distribués des pigments
biologiques qui déterminent la couleur
et ces pigments ce sont les mélanine
dont les magazines féminins nous repart
le tous les étés en fait il existe deux
types de mélanine la Féo mélanine qui
est un pigment jeune rouge que tout le
monde produit et le mélanine un pigment
marron noir le même que celui qui nous
fait bronzer la couleur visible des
poils et des cheveux dépend de la
quantité de mélanine présente qui peut
varier considérablement si le Mélanie
n'est présentant grande quantité la
couleur est très sombre et moins il y en
a plus la couleur tente de façon
continue vers le châtain le blond puis
le roux et quand il n'y a aucune des
mélanine la personne est albinos et ses
cheveux sont quasi blancs
clairement toi tes rousses ouais mais
non c'est pas si évident quand tu
mélanges du noir et du orange à partir
de quel moment tu vas passer de c'est
plutôt orange assez plutôt noir
par contre toi tu es clairement chaud
les roues ils ont des taches de rousseur
c'est pas pour rien ça s'appelle comme
ça oui mais Mario est-ce qu'elle est
rousse non je sais pas rousse non voilà
et il y a un chercheur qui a essayé en
1952 qui a fait le test il a analysé des
cheveux il a vu que bah dedans il y
avait de la fée au mélanine partout et
que ça varié de façon continue du brun
au roux on avait de moins en moins de
mélanine donc dire roue par où c'est
arbitraire
ça surtout après la soirée d'hier
d'ailleurs vous êtes passé où vous
et oui même si la couleur de cheveux des
enfants peut changer dans les premières
années de la vie la couleur de nos
cheveux à l'âge adulte était résistèrent
donc tout naturellement je suis allé
voir du côté de la génétique pour tenter
d'y trouver une raison à l'odeur des
roues dans la membrane de nous
mélanocytes il y a un récepteur qui
lorsqu'il en reçoit le signal déclenche
la production de mélanine en l'absence
de signal c'est la Féo mélanine
uniquement qui est produite la forme de
ce récepteur est codée par un gène nommé
comme le récepteur mélanocorty one
réceptor ou MC1R situé chez l'homme sur
le chromosome 16 quand ce jeune comporte
des mutations le récepteur a une forme
qui lui permet moins bien de reconnaître
le signal et il déclenche alors moins
souvent la production de Mélanie c'est
de là que vient l'explication simpliste
de l'origine de la rousseur que l'on
croise souvent sauf que non déjà dans
les années 90 les généticiens ont
découvert que différentes mutations du
gène Mcar pouvait entraîner une
chevelure rousse mais en 2018 grâce aux
nouvelles banques de données fournies
par les tests ADN grand public une étude
menée sur près de 350 000 profils
génétiques au Royaume-Uni déjà montré
que le gène MC1R ne serait pas
responsable à lui seul de la couleur
rousse la majorité des personnes
porteuses des mutations de ce gène sur
leurs deux allèles sont d'ailleurs
blondes ou châtain clair l'étude montre
ainsi que pas moins de 8 autres gènes
serait impliqués dans l'apparition de
larousseur modifiant la forme du
récepteur ou inhibant la production de
mélanine et les chercheurs ont au
passage recensés près de 200 versions
différentes du gène MC1R donc non être
roux ne se réduit pas à l'histoire d'un
simple gêne tout comme la couleur de la
peau la rousseur est un caractère
polygiénique ce qui n'est finalement pas
très difficile à croire quand on regarde
la très grande diversité des couleurs et
des types de cheveux que l'on rassemble
sous cette même appellation roux du coup
il y a des parents roux qui ont des
enfants qui sont par où et il y a même
des jumeaux
identiques qui naissent un roux et un
parent tu sais qu'on peut parler d'autre
chose et l'odeur alors
corporelle est propre à chacun individu
et elle est encore plus caractéristique
que l'ADN puisque deux jumeaux n'auront
pas la même odeur corporelle elle
comprend plusieurs composantes qui
varient au cours de la vie et en
fonction de la santé de l'alimentation
de l'hygiène des hormones des émotions
etc mais aussi une composante de fonds
génétiquement acquise puisqu'on cherche
une odeur liée au caractère héréditaire
roux on va chercher du côté de cette
composante de fond qui est déterminée
par la nature des sécrétions de la peau
et les bactéries qui la peuplent oui
parce que attention ça va peut-être vous
choquer mais les sécrétions de la peau
ne sont pas parfumées contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire ça n'est pas la
sueur elle-même qui pue ce sont les
bactéries héberger sur notre peau qui se
charge de transformer les molécules
diluées dans la transpiration en un
nuage de puanteur donc une odeur
différente ce sont des sécrétions de la
peau différente et ou des bactéries
différentes mais cherchez une odeur de
la peau propre rousse et aux roues ça
implique un premier raccourci discutable
le caractère
concerne la couleur de cheveux pas la
peau beaucoup de bruns ou de blonds ont
ce qu'on appelle une peau de roue très
claire par exemple ou avec des taches de
rousseur comme Marie non je suis pas
rousse tu arrêtes avec ça
donc eux aussi devraient puer ensuite
être roux on l'a vu c'est tout en
ensemble de couleurs qui apparaissent
par défaut à cause des très faibles
doses de mélanine dans les poils les
cheveux et souvent dans la peau les
scientifiques ayant montré que l'autre
pigment la Féo mélanine est présente
dans toutes les peaux et si on imagine
comme Madame Le Figaro par exemple que
la source de l'odeur des roues c'est 7
faits au mélanine tout le monde devrait
dégager cette odeur déso sans compter
que ce raisonnement passe sous silence
que les pigments ne sont détectés qu'en
quantité infime dans la sueur alors
qu'elle contient par ailleurs plein
d'autres molécules sécrétées par la peau
en bien plus grande quantité
identifier elle comme les précurseurs
des mauvaises odeurs plus précisément
les sécrétions de la peau proviennent de
trois types de glandes
[Musique]
donc j'ai essayé de retrouver l'histoire
l'origine du préjugé quoi et j'ai essayé
de trouver des textes qu'ils le
mentionnait et là bah évidemment je
trouve pas grand chose à part
éventuellement la plus ancienne source
serait genre Aristote qui aurait dit
dans un texte que les roues c'est la
rousseur c'était une infirmité du poil
oui alors bon je ne vais pas te laisser
dire n'importe quoi sur Aristote quand
même tu peux parler de ma calvitie mais
Aristote on déconne pas cette phrase là
le rouge serait une affirmité du poil
elle n'existe pas sur Aristote c'est
souvent répété même encore aujourd'hui
mais vraiment dans toute lave d'Aristote
il y a quasi pas de mention de
larousseur et en tout cas pas cette
phrase là ce qu'on a par contre c'est un
traité qui s'appelle les physiognomonica
qui a eu beaucoup d'importance au 10e
siècle on est même beaucoup le lire
parce que ça rejoignait beaucoup d'idées
qui étaient très en vogue au 19e siècle
cette idée de lire le caractère des gens
sur leur physionomie et effectivement
dans ce traité là qui est plein
d'horreur par ailleurs il y a aussi un
passage sur les roues ou qui sont
comparés à un renard parce que c'est la
même couleur et les renards sont plutôt
fourbes donc les roues seraient fourbes
c'est pas très sympa mais en tout cas ce
traité même s'il a été attribué à aristo
pendant très longtemps de fait il est
pas d'Aristote et cette obsession sur
les roues elle semble vraiment pas venir
des Grecs pour autant que je sache ouais
du coup je sais pas en l'Antiquité
comment ils étaient vus les roues alors
l'éconotation sur la rousseur à
l'Antiquité c'est pas lié aux odeurs
enfin chez y chez les Grecs donc Piros
roux c'est un adjectif qu'on utilise
pour qualifier les barbares et
principalement les barbares qui viennent
du nord couplé avec l'adjectif Glaucos
donc les yeux bleus pairs et les deux
ensemble ça connote un aspect inquiétant
mais aussi une ardeur guerrière une
fougue indomptable etc donc dangereuse
et violente par contre donc c'est pas
c'est rarement quelque chose qui
qualifie le grec lambda on va dire mais
néanmoins et ça peut paraître
contradictoire c'est quand même un
prénom pyros chez les Grecs il y a
endroits qui sont appelés comme ça donc
on pourrait se dire étrange un prénom
connoté comme ça pour des rois pas si
étranges car c'est quand même un
adjectif qu'on utilise pour qualifier
Achille le plus grand des héros de la
guerre de Troie qui dans son adolescence
était roux donc on l'appelait Achille de
ROM mais quand il était jeune donc avec
toujours cette idée voilà de fougue de
la jeunesse hein donc table etc mais
quand Achille il devient adulte et qui
part à la guerre de Troie on qualifie
plutôt de blond et le blond c'est le
doré c'est la couleur des dieux la
lumière etc donc bah il y a une
connotation pas forcément très positif
avec l'adjectif roux mais bon ça peut
quand même être un prénom droit mais en
tout cas pas d'association à une odeur
particulière à ma connaissance donc
c'est vraiment une espèce de reprise au
19e siècle d'idées qu'on avait plus ou
moins dites à l'Antiquité auquel on
rajoute des préjugés qui sont juste de
cette époque là
la méfiance envers les roues et les
idées reçues existent donc depuis bien
longtemps et ce sont intensifiés dans
les sociétés judéochrétiennes mais la
mention de la mauvaise odeur des roues
et étrangement assez récentes les
premières références littéraires et
scientifiques sur l'odeur des roues
remontent en fait aux années 1800
Gustave Flaubert écrit ainsi en 1857
dans Madame Bovary l'odeur des roues
pénétrer à travers la muraille pendant
les consultations de même que l'on
entendait de la cuisine les malades
toussés dans le cabinet et débité toute
leur histoire mais ce sont dans les
ouvrages scientifiques de l'époque que
l'on retrouve le plus d'allusions au
parfum roux il faut dire que dans la
deuxième moitié du XIXe siècle les
odeurs deviennent une préoccupation
centrale dans la société alors qu'au
siècle précédent clairement ça pue la
mort une véritable sensibilité olfactive
voit le jour notamment grâce au
développement de l'hygiène et des
parfums les odeurs corporelles alors
intimement liées à la morale font
l'objet de tout un tas de traités
scientifiques à une époque où les
médecins raffolent des typologies et
analyse les moindres détails de la
physiologie des corps particulier du
corps féminin les experts est-ce odeurs
de l'époque établissent alors une
classification des odeurs corporelles en
fonction de la couleur de peau et y
associe la couleur de cheveux le docteur
Augustin galopin de loin mon hygiéniste
préféré du 19e siècle établi ainsi en
1886 dans le parfum de la femme et le
sens olfactif dans l'amour 11 catégories
d'odeurs de femmes depuis 1 la négresse
et la mulatresse avec toutes les nuances
de chocolat ou de pain d'épices à 11 la
rousse pure tavelée cheveux et poils
abondants peau blanche taché de son
quelquefois des yeux noirs d'une
originalité toute particulière regard
étrange et fascinateur de belles dents
des lèvres ou mince Alexis ou charnelle
souvent affecté de pialisme qui n'est
pas sans inconvénient et sans odeur
parfum très caractéristique fin ou très
recherchés oui le pianisme c'est l'excès
de salive la médecine du 19e siècle se
nourrit forcément des représentations
sociales de l'époque et contribuent
parfois à les justifier par des
explications scientifiques pour vous
situer c'est quand même cette belle
époque où on justifie scientifiquement
le colonialisme le docteur Charles
Ferret tente donc des 1892 de relier les
sécrétions de la peau et l'odeur des
roues les odeurs des sécrétions cutanées
varient beaucoup suivant les individus
les roues ont souvent une odeur plus
pénétrante avant que le docteur
Ernest Monin propose enfin en 1904 une
explication scientifique à cette
spécificité beaucoup de personnes et
particulièrement les femmes rousses
exaltes lorsqu'elles ont très chaud une
odeur sûre fort désagréable qui est due
aux acides valérianiques et caproïques
éliminé par la sueur une explication qui
semblerait bancale aujourd'hui mais tout
à fait plausible avec les connaissances
de l'époque quand même s'entend avant
madame Le Figaro c'est le acide ayant
tout juste été découverts et produits
pour la parfumerie au 19e siècle on
découvre aussi les sulfureuses écrits du
markisad et en 1904 justement les 120
journées de Sodome ou l'école du
libertinage rédigé sa captivité à la
Bastille et publiée pour la première
fois en version complète et à noter
scientifiquement par le docteur allemand
Ivan Bloch parmi les 600 perversions et
sévices sexuelles présentées le marquis
tsad mentionne un homme qui affectionne
particulièrement les odeurs de
transpiration sous les aisselles des
femmes et pour qui on fait venir une
jeune fille rousse le psychiatre à note
là le cas numéro 22 décrit un fétichiste
olfactif qui comme on sait préfère les
femmes rousses dont l'odeur est
particulièrement forte ainsi que sad
l'explique aussi dans ce cas en effet on
retrouve un peu plus loin un personnage
qui explique que ces femmes là vous ne
l'ignorez point Monseigneur ont dans
cette partie un fumée infiniment plus
violent le préjugé de l'odeur est l'un
des rares qui est attribué aux hommes
comme aux femmes mais il se retrouve
beaucoup plus souvent mentionné pour les
femmes et ses écrits montrent combien il
est lié à la sexualité depuis le
Moyen-âge la rousseur des femmes est en
général associée au péché or au XIXe
siècle l'odeur est justement utilisée
pour dénigrer les prostituées donc le
lien O rapport sexualité rousse et quasi
immédiat et devient très populaire et le
King pour l'odeur des Rousses trouve un
intérêt particulier aux yeux des
médecins alors que la psychiatrie se
développe et que la sexologie voit le
jour l'historienne de la littérature
Valérie André a justement exploré toutes
les références aux roues et aux Rousses
et elle note que le préjugé sur l'odeur
a aussi parcouru les 19e et 20e siècle
dans une multitude de romans à travers
des personnages féminins nana la
prostituée rousse de Zola la fille de
Charles Swan dans À la recherche du
temps perdu de Proust la mère Vitruve
dans Mort à crédit de Céline autant de
rousses dont l'odeur est mentionnée plus
ou moins subtilement et évidemment plus
proche de nous le parfum publié par
l'autorament su skin dans 1985 est
récemment adapté en série Netflix repose
sur ce même préjugé du coup les roues ne
puent pas non c'est principalement la
photo 19e siècle si tout le monde s'est
mis à penser ça
quoi le rapport avec le 19e siècle alors
mais chouchou tout un rapport avec le
XIXe siècle alors oui c'est sûr il y a
quelques siècles il y avait beaucoup
plus d'odeurs corporelles qu'aujourd'hui
on sentait sûrement beaucoup plus les
différences entre les gens mais est-ce
qu'on pouvait identifier une odeur
particulière associée à un groupe de
personnes aussi divers que les roues et
pourquoi la mentionner si tard dans tous
les cas l'odeur reste un puissant moteur
de discrimination puisqu'elle est encore
peu expliquée scientifiquement et
surtout parce qu'elle fait appel au sens
et pas à la raison et les études
sociologiques montrent que la mauvaise
odeur fait partie des premiers attributs
donnés à la race inférieure dans les
idéologies racistes juste après c'est
les sauvages et juste avant ils mangent
des trucs dégueu donc tout me pousse à
penser que le parfum des roues c'est
juste une construction sociale qui est
venue alimenter une discrimination sur
le physique qui a existait déjà ouais
enfin tu dis ça parce que contrairement
à moi toi tu es rose c'est tout
j'avoue que j'ai moi-même grandi avec
l'idée reçue que les roues semblent
différemment et en me lançant dans cet
épisode je m'attendais vraiment à tomber
sur une explication médicale au préjugés
ou sur une étude bien ficelée qui prouve
le contraire mais non j'ai rien trouvé
qui traite directement du sujet
d'ailleurs si on vous prétend qu'une
telle étude scientifique existe
méfiez-vous il y a de fortes chances que
ce soit une fois info et c'est
finalement la littérature et la
sociologie qui nous donne des pistes
d'explications et il y a sûrement
plusieurs raisons à cela déjà vu que il
représente que 2% de la population
mondiale cherchait si les roues ont une
odeur corporelle différente ça me semble
pas spécialement porteur comme sujet
d'étude mais surtout ce serait se lancer
dans une recherche qui stigmatise un
ensemble de personnes sur la base d'un
caractère physique est-ce qu'on est
vraiment sûr que c'est une bonne idée
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que vous sentez bon et
n'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire
partager rejoignez-nous sur le discord
et puis si vous regardez cette vidéo à
sa sortie on est en live tout de suite
je suis sur twitch et vous pouvez venir
discuter avec moi de mon odeur ou de la
vôtre
il fait vraiment une étude exhaustive de
l'odeur des corps regarde pour ne rien
omettre mentionnons ici l'odeur du
smegma prépucial fade et aromatique à la
fois elle rappelle l'odeur de marée
d'écrevisses cuites
avec ça
[Musique]
mais du coup vous avez une âme OK